these sports come and go that's just the
way things work nothing lasts forever
and the fact the matter is we're all
just playing video games on product
cycles the NBA doesn't have to release a
sequel to basketball every two years but
most game publishers do which is often
what leads to the death of the
corresponding eSports scene a decade ago
halo was the biggest game in North
American eSports
commanding millions of dollars in prize
money strong viewership and millions of
copies sold
now it's lucky to get 10,000 viewers on
Twitch on a good day this is how halo
rose to the top of the eSports world
final thoughts your 2010 MLG national
champions
fell as hard as any game ever has
Michigan Sturgis ain't happening AGL 10k
is supposed to be next weekend that's on
you [ __ ] this is your fault
and then somehow managed to put together
a redemption story
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
the original halo was a huge deal for
Microsoft
halo combat Evolved rated M for Mature
it was the flagship game for their brand
new console the Xbox in 2001 no one knew
if Microsoft would sink or swim in the
games industry and pay low the cutting
edge fast-paced first-person shooter
from little-known Mac developer Bungie
was Microsoft a way of showing that they
knew what they were doing with the power
of the GeForce to GTS shading rasterizer
plasma burns look more realistic than
ever before and videos GeForce to GTS
and bungees halo the game was a hit
selling 5 million copies and inspiring a
small but dedicated base of competitive
player
[Applause]
I'm in position Laurie I'll do the flag
do prize pools were small but players
wanted organization so handful players
and fans banded together to create MLG
an organization that would go on to make
halo eSports huge MLG was kind of was
born out of Mike and my love of video
games we were sitting there at I said
why don't we just run one of these
tournaments and just see how it works it
was a leap of faith a few years later
Microsoft and Bungie launched halo 2
which was better in just about every way
the gameplay was better the maps were
better even the sales were better with 8
million soul of the halo spies and that
momentum propelled halo to the top of
the North American eSports scene Europe
had counter-strike and dota Korea and
Starcraft and na final bosses your 2007
Boost Mobile MLG pro circuit champions
hundred thousand dollars richer and even
more importantly those guys were themed
for last season collapse the era of Halo
2 & 3 was dominated by legendary teams
like carbon final boss and straight
trippin
in 2006 MLG worked out a deal with the
USA network to broadcast MLG tournaments
on TV and episodes were later available
on Xbox Live re squad one shot G squared
take it out
that's rough 52-48 that game gonna go to
the way but it went final boss' way they
leave five games to do MLG ran dozens of
Halo tournaments between 2005 and 2007
and only stopped to bring in halo three
halo three cracked 14 million copies
sold booing its predecessor's out of the
water and throwing MLG's events into an
even higher gear
every halo tournament emoji ran gave out
over $50,000 in prize money higher than
anything in na at the time with annual
$280,000 championship
I called it early and then they
straight Griffin soul
it's time they gave up and then becoming
our 2008 halo 3 national champions MLG
quickly became the biggest esports
tournament organizer in north america
off the back of their success with halo
adding Super Smash Bros Tekken Rainbow
six Call of Duty and Gears of War
Ultimate agrees of success what we did
was go out and find all of the best kind
of grassroots level people who are
running these great tournaments and
brought them in and then we really
developed majorly gaming halo 3 was a
great competitive game but only after
MLG and fans made a few small tweaks to
the game's competitive settings most
notably pro players disabled equipment a
new feature at at the halo 3 that really
changed the way the game was played but
with all that turned off halo 3 was a
great competitive game and it looked to
be carrying Halo into a bright future
that is until reach Halo Reach Falls
2010 it was no secret that Bungie and
Microsoft were going through a breakup
Bungie wanted independence to make new
games but their agreement with Microsoft
meant that they had to make a few more
Halo games before they could finally get
it it's such an important cultural ideal
here that the studio owns what it
creates independence was going to be the
only thing that was gonna be able to
allow us to do what we wanted to do the
deal was essentially we make a couple
more Halo games we leave halo with
Microsoft and we can split amicably so I
mean ultimately the price of our freedom
was to to leave our baby behind to move
from being Halo developers to Halo fans
so Bungie took a chance to experiment
first came
oh D ST a mostly single-player game that
didn't affect halos competitive scene at
all then in 2010 they put out Halo Reach
a game that carried forward bungees a
legacy of excellent single-player
campaigns but if all of the equipment
system from Halo 3 into something much
worse for the competitive Sam you might
be surprised to hear that when Halo
Reach came out it was met with backlash
from the halo community I vividly
remember the uproar on the budgee forms
there were threads upon threads of
players upset with the game claiming
that it didn't feel like halo and that
everything that made halo great was gone
I vividly remember not enjoying the
multiplayer for three main reasons
number one the maps number two the
weapons and number three armor abilities
reach had several problems equipment was
replaced by armor ability abilities
included active camouflage which made
you completely invisible armor off which
made you invincible before releasing a
pulse of damage and jetpack which what
you fly and then there's bloom that was
sprint there was there was armor lock
that wasn't the first time one D
tournament there was jetpack and all
that stuff does not belong in hill
thanks to new blue mechanic full auto
had no spray pattern it was entirely
random accuracy meant stopping which was
a far cry for the way top players had
experienced halo in the past there's so
many things that are wrong with this
game that can be fixed in a very small
amount of time and that needs to happen
during this four month offseason that
we're gonna have with MLG okay Bungie
and later three four three
halos new development team eventually
let players turn off blue and armor
abilities and even let them have default
starting low debts but by then the game
that competitive reach players were
experiencing was so far from what the
average player was playing that they
weren't even the same game they still
ran a reach but it was second to
Starcraft 2 and League of Legends which
will quickly picking up steam in North
America thanks to strong developments
important MLG only ran a handful of
reach events but the community strength
alongside their game and MLG had to
remove halo as the flagship game on
their circuit halo is just is just
headed down man but if a reach Frank
halos community then it was halo 4 that
truly killed it we've really focused on
trying to craft these moments that live
up to the legacy of the Halo experience
were working within the constraints of
what makes halo halo but trying to make
every aspect of it they're going back
three four threes first foray into
developing a Halo game of their own was
something of a disaster on all fronts
the game sold four point seven nine
million copies but the disappointing
single-player was coupled with an
absolute a mess of a multiplayer
experience there was no online ranked
play the launch maps were terrible and
not only were armored ability still
around they were part of the unpopular
loadout system from reach there has been
something done to this game that
enjoy the matchmaking experience has to
be better the game has to be more fun
and obviously you know I'm gonna sit in
a ranks spectator mode make the game not
suck go back to the formula the online
experience has to be better you don't
have to reinvent the wheel for your
matchmaking experience when it will too
when halo 3 both paved the way for this
it just wasn't halo anymore MLG ran
exactly one halo 4 tournament the week
the game came out leaving a lot of
people to question exactly how
legitimate it was given there were
accusations that some players had access
to the game early MLG first-ever halo 4
champions
we'll go down in history this weekend
we'll go down in history look through
guys necks even after the sheer number
of people who left halo during reach
halo 4 was a death blow for an already
small community fans tried and tried but
no one could find a way to make
competitive halo for fun and balanced
and then yet again they also didn't give
us Rick a real ranking system that we
could see like they saying that we
couldn't do it and they took forever to
fix the bolt shot and the maps were kind
of iffy and they still had Sprint and
the four shot became like six months
later and abilities absence other
tournament organizers rose up to fill
the gap arena gaming League ran
tournament between 2012 and 2013 but
collapsed amidst allegations that
employees in tournament winners work
being paged
right at a geotag they're like oh yeah
we're gonna have [ __ ] a bore and then
oh wait three weeks before people have
already bought team passes for him a
four [ __ ] you was watching Table three
no refund [ __ ] off right and then they
cancelled the event because II bash
which is where they were trying to hold
it in Indianapolis wasn't even created
yet it was still being built and Brad
just decided to market it and pocket
that money it is important to know all
the way up to a GL 10 Brad played
favorites with who he paid out besides a
select few no one no one got paid dating
all the way back to Ajo six all that
were left were the hardest of the
hardcore playing in small grassroots
tournaments attempts were made to move
back to older damage the way that Super
Smash Bros in melee has survived more
than a decade after its launch but the
community was already too small to
sustain further fragmentation halo was
well and truly dead but there is a happy
ending to this story in 2014 343 put out
the Master Chief collection along with a
port of Halo two's multiplayer mode
which brought a lot of lapsed pros and
fans back into the scene it's extremely
smooth it felt very clean as the 60
frames per second all that sprint was
taken out of the game which means a lot
more setup based game types are being
played
the still will see they're playing out
this baby on say time T squared the last
player he'll know let's go ahead and see
what Roy's up to Roy has an angle jul 5
2014 election launched Invitational
champions what a series that was the
game wasn't perfect and took a long time
to get fixed but it was a step in the
right direction
1 2 3 4 3 followed up with halo 5 just a
year later
halo 5 replaced armor abilities with
Spartan abilities always on traits that
every player had constant access to with
the option to turn individual powers on
or off for competitive play it got back
to default starts back to solid map
design and away from killstreak gimmicks
trimmed from cause it was a return to
form the shooting is definitely really
really like easy but the movement makes
it much harder to huge than like any
other like Halo if you like and then put
like MLG coming back they run events so
well it's a bus and everybody is crazy
and with the event through one-of-a-kind
Highland 5 brought us the first ever
Halo title with a live spectate auction
this means you can jump into any players
live film and watch on a 1 minute delay
whether it be a pro player whether it be
one of your buddies with the one minute
delay it had its limitations this leads
me into my second point of what what
halo 5 has done well and that is the
observer mode in Halo 5 now observer
mode allows us to join any lobby and
watch without that one minute delay not
only that it has enhanced viewer
information on the user interface to see
each player shields whether they have a
powerup what weapons they have an AIDS
they have selected with the right
guidance and hopefully with some more
tweaking in Halo Infinite the next title
we could see a really classy spectate
slash observer mode halo 5 also had
eSports support from Microsoft on day
one following up the two seasons of the
Halo championship series they played on
the Master Chief collection after that
the league moved to halo 5 and Microsoft
boosted the prize pool to 1 million the
halo community brought that up to 2.5
million dollars in 2016 and the 1
million dollar prize pool stuck
for the next two years Elle town is
actually putting this bike there now
trying to get this bike back look at
allegiance they are moving together and
they might be able to still get this
going counter logic gaming
halo world champions of 2016 what a run
they've had all season long an
incredible squad and it is well-deserved
they have fought and fought and fought
for this opportunity
halo still doesn't pick up massive
viewership but it's in a much better
place than it was even two years ago
proteins are coming in to give pro
players salaries prize pools are
sustainable and viewership does trend
upwards during major events
[Music]
[Applause]
what
[Music]
it's been a long
to this point they've lost a lot of
tournaments to splice but here we are
again in a second best-of-seven put it
all together and we can learn at least
one important thing from Halo and it's
fall from grace if you make a good game
people are going to play it and if you
make a bad game well you better hope the
community can hold on a long enough
until you make a better one darkman is
the 2002 pelo national champion
$20,000 by finishing first place
congratulations
final boss' your 2007 Boost Mobile MLG
pro circuit champions 2008 halo 3 4
before champions straight ribbon 2009
major league gaming national champions
believe the hype
final boss year 2010 MLG mess
national champions instant
[Applause]
Championship Series season two
champion
take gaming
20:17
champions
hey no it's finished no I think we're
just getting started
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button